jetzt wird ihm aufgefallen sein es ist
wahlkampf in deutschland das erkennen
sie zum beispiel daran dass die großen
parteien gerade wieder sachen
versprechen diese schon seit jahren
hätten machen können weil sie regieren
jetzt gerade kam die meldung deutschland
ist bei alleinstehenden menschen vize
weltmeister in sachen steuern und
abgaben um mittlere einkommen werden bei
uns generell stärker belastet als
wirklich hohe warum werden die kalte
progression und der sogenannte
mittelstandsbauch nicht endlich
beseitigt hat mich ein weiser mann aus
dem alten land schon 2014 gesagt wenn
wir wer in einer ganzen
legislaturperiode diesbezüglich nichts
tun dann steht die bundestagswahl vor
der tür und dann fragen wir aber jetzt
versprechen wir euch ganz sicher für
direkte legislatur liebe freunde das
nimmt und niemand ab
dass ich keiner ab denn nun steht die
bundestagswahl vor der tür und ihr
versprecht uns das ganze jahr für den
mächtigen statur diesmal in echt jetzt
also ich würde mich einfach stehen
schämen und gar nix mehr versprechen
sogar wolfgang schäuble
der alte pfennigfuchser macht neuerdings
mit bei den schwarzen bis zu 15
milliarden will er uns demnächst
vielleicht von unserem eigenen geld
schenken das ganze selbstherrliche
gelaber ermüdet mittlerweile sogar
interview profis und wenn ich das alles
zusammen mache dann ist das
allerwichtigste dass wir mit einer
maßvollen stetigen verlässlichen politik
das fortsetzen was du in den letzten
jahren erreicht
anreise flüge wirkstoffentwicklung keine
angst die kollegin ist wieder aufgewacht
als er mit dem kopf auf die tischplatte
geknallt wir müssen endlich mal
diskutieren wo für das steuergeld
ausgegeben wird
der feind ist die deutschen gießkanne
ein beispiel familienpolitik da gibt der
staat jedes jahr 200 milliarden aus für
familienpolitik aber nur sieben prozent
davon gehen an besonders bedürftige
familien
warum kriegen reiche kindergeld warum
gibt es im deutschen überhaupt das wort
ehegattensplitting kostenlose kita für
alle auch für wohlhabende warum also was
bisher der renner es im wahlkampf gar
nicht wirklich sagen ist die kostenlose
kita absorbiert das der renner ist im
wahlkampf